Former first lady Michelle Obama said.
And this, you know,
obviously was very significant.
She she's raising some alarm bells
as far as 2024 is concerned.
She says she's terrified,
her word terrified about the election.
Listen to this.
What's going to happen
in this next election?
I am terrified
about what could possibly happen
because our leaders matter,
who we select,
who speaks for us,
who holds that bully pulpit.
It affects us in ways
that sometimes
I think people take for granted.
Very stark warning from her
about the challenges
the Democrats face coming up in November.
Yet, look,
she's never been shy
about these kinds of things.
And it also don't
forget that
her husband, Barack Obama,
recently met with Joe Biden
and gave some advice
about what
he ought to do with his campaign.
That is maybe move
some of the people
from the White House to the campaign.
And so I think, you know,
this is a couple
that talks to each other.
And I think you can presume
that they both feel the same way.
They're looking at the same polls
that we're looking at.
They're looking at the fact
that he's losing
a lot of key constituencies
like younger voters
and and Hispanic voters.
And so I think she's speaking her truth,
as we say, and she's not shy about it.
Let me bring Ashley Ellison
into this conversation.
She's a former Obama White House
senior policy adviser.
It's not just the former
first lady
raising these alarm bells
as far as Democrats are concerned.
The Democratic congressman
from South Carolina, Jim Clyburn,
as we just heard in that report,
he says he's also very concerned
about black voters
simply not showing up to vote this time.
What do you think?
Well, look,
we know black voters
resurrected Joe Biden's
campaign in the primary
in the state of South
Carolina with the help of Mr. Clyburn.
We also know
Joe Biden can't win
without a large
historical number of black voters
turning out for elections
like they did in 2020.
People say this all the time,
but I'm not sure they actually believe it
in their actions. Speak to this.
Black folks are not a monolith.
And so older
black voters may feel one way
about a certain issue.
Younger black millennial voters
may feel a certain way.
I don't.
There are some black voters
that will vote for Donald Trump.
I don't think that the risk is that
50% of black voters
vote for Donald Trump.
But not showing up is just as much a vote
for Donald Trump.
And so
when we hear the former first lady
say that we all
remember the day Donald Trump watched
and many of us were devastated
and had to go back to the White House
the very next day
and listen to the president address
this in the Rose Garden.
And then we live
four years of his presidency
and saw some of the egregious policies
that he implemented
that really did hurt black people.
And so the risk,
I think, the terrifying nature
that we all of is
can we
endure another
four years of Donald Trump?
And I don't want to have to.
And so
the campaign is going to have to speak
and convince
those black voters to show up.
That was one of the reasons, I'm sure,
why President Biden was in South Carolina
today, as we all saw.
You know, Scott Jennings,
Nikki Haley has been dealing
with the fallout from her comments
about the Civil War.
But now Donald Trump
is contending with his own
really controversial
comments on that subject,
as well as several other key subjects.
I want you and our viewers to watch this.
I love studying the
if you take a look I mean, the words
I don't know what it is.
The Civil War was so fascinating,
so horrible.
I know it very well.
I know the whole process
that they went through
and they just couldn't get along.
And that would have been something
that could have been negotiated
and they wouldn't have had that problem.
John McCain, for some reason, couldn't
get his arm up that I remember.
He goes that like that.
That was the end of that
Crooked Joe is staging is pathetic
fear mongering campaign
event in Pennsylvania today.
Did you see him?
He was stuttering
through the whole thing.
He's got up by
got a he's a threat to democracy.
He's a threat to our democracy.
Well,
they had to release the six hostages
they've suffered and now
they had a releasing
I call them hostages.
Some people call them prisoners.
They are not hostages.
Hostages are individuals
who were at a music festival.
And we're grabbed by terrorists
and taken to Gaza
or their family members.
These are people who either decided
to plead guilty
to crimes
or were convicted
in a courtroom of crimes.
They're not hostages, clearly.
Right, Scott?
Yeah,
I think the most egregious thing
he said there was about
calling these people hostages.
I know
it's become fashionable
on the right to refer to them that way,
but you said it, Wolf.
These people
are going through
the criminal justice process.
Some have been convicted,
some pled guilty,
Some are still going to trial.
But what happened that day was horrible.
These people are not hostages.
I know people
and you know, people
who were in the capital
that day who feared for their lives.
It was a terrible day.
But this is obviously
he think's going to be motivating
for his political base.
I will just tell you,
I personally think
it's extremely limiting
for him politically
because there's
a whole bunch of independents
and even some Democrats
who are not happy with Joe Biden
but don't want to have anything
to do
with the idea of
whitewashing January six
for calling these people hostages
or trying to claim
something happened that day
that is different than what
we all saw with our own eyes.
Yeah, absolutely.
All right, guys, thank
you very, very much.